to talk about a very cool event to bring
awareness to something that a lot of
people deal with we have joey custy and
cole mom joining us today to tell us
about something that people deal with
all the time and that is asthma tell us
well welcome guys and tell us a little
bit about this event that's happening
all right so
first of all we have a 383 soccer
tournament going on this sunday
we have about 12 teams right now we're
trying to look to get it up a little bit
more but really what this event is all
centered around is asthma so um
one of the players from each team will
be wearing like a mask you know to uh
sort of stiffen their breathing a little
bit to emulate what it is like to
actually have asthma themselves a lot of
people
deal with this every day i know i have
people in my family that you know carry
around their you know the what are they
called
inhalers i know
and then and they can't they can't
function without it really my brother
has to have one at all times and so
you're one one person on each team is
gonna play with this mask on so it's
gonna be like mimicking the effects of
having asthma have you guys tried this
before yes we have it's really hard
you're doing this to raise money how can
people get involved how can they help
okay so we actually have a few
opportunities first off we have a raffle
that people can participate in um 20 a
ticket we have a bunch of cool prizes
and whatnot and we also have a gofundme
as of right now we've raised about uh 3
300 so um pretty good support from the
community so far and we're looking to
raise that up to about 5 000. let's do
that let's get that to happen so tell us
this is happening at the betty wilson
park and people can come out and uh
support june 19th right and you said you
want to get you want to get people to
sign up for it anyone can sign up or how
does that work
we have a google form you can sign up uh
we're doing 16 plus uh just because a
lot of older guys are playing uh five
people a team but three play at the same
time and then uh it's only 50 a team so
it's pretty cheap for a tournament and
all the proceeds go to aafa
asthma and allergy foundation america to
you know try and uh help awareness what
a great thing you guys are doing thank
you so much the asthma awareness soccer
tournament is happening again june 19th
at 9 a.m betty wilson park so make sure
you support and help these guys raise
some money for a great cause jillian